Mặt lánh đạo đảng đã nước, cậm bị thứ tốt lâm, bị thứ của nguy trung hương đã trao gánh hiểu
Anh hùng lực lượng vũ trang nhân dân sau thậm cuộc khậu cần, khi thuộc khó phòng, vì đã có thành rất đặc biệt sức sắc trong một luyện
Thắng trang trên đấu, sây dự quân độ nhân dân cùng của khó phòng có phần và sự giật sây dựng chủ miếng sấu và bảo vệ thuộc
Cậm bị thu giền địa chút mừng với thành rất đặc biệt sức sắc, mà sống cuộc khậu cần, khi thuật đã được xong thời gian qua
Nhìn mạnh, tổng cuộc khó cần chỉ thuật cần chủ động dự báo, mạnh đã suyên phát triển qua phần sự của thế giới, lấy mạnh mình cứu, ứng dùng thành trường qua phương vệ luổi mới thẳng, và chuyện độ số xong của lý, bất thành, kết kế, chế tạo, hạnh có, sự chứa, chế dại hóa khu khí, chạm bị ý phật, hạnh có chất hậu cần, và tư cái phật, nhất là các chủng và múc khí, hạnh bị ý phật có ý nhất trên lượng, tương tạo rất lượng như chỉ qua học, tại các tất cả trở về cứu, các nhà trường xong tổng cuộc và hạnh hộ cần, ý phật hộ cần, ý phật hộ
tiền quên mới ngay hậu cần, cí thuật cô nói đây đau với đổi mới, phảo cô ngay, từ tuyến thành tự mũ nhất.
Nhận lại ước kiế tối đến loại để ứng dùng qua sự phát triển qua con thực, qua sự, cô ngoths, ngay nàng hóa đất nước, xam phòng của tảing cuộc.
là cô ngành hậu cần, cí thuật cô nói, phải là những xam phòng, xoan ngành, những xam phòng, lướng dột ngày Mozh d doctr tây.
sẽ xin tình thành tình lực trụ từ cơm và từ hảo dân tập.
Và đặc biệt, nhấn mạnh, vỉ tự trụ, chứ lực, quán chẳng và chẳng thay từ giải quà
2 kinh lịch 2 đại, 2 đại, 2 ngờ, và phương chăm ghram hướng,
chính chỉ hướng, kỳ hướng, công nghệ hướng, ngệ thật quân xử hướng,
đời xong bộ rối hướng.
Tổ bị thương cho mạnh, cần chú chào, quan tâm, chăm lâu đời xong bộ rối,
đứ bứ ăn nơi ổ, xinh hoạc, đến chăm sóc trước quay, nhấn là đối với những cạnh mộ,
chến xí ở phùng sau, phùng ra, nơi bên dưới 2 đảo,
để bụ đồ ít tâm công tác, khăn sản xin đấu,
coi đây là sọng tâm công tác hủy ổ, thường xuyên của ngành hậu cần ký phật.
Thọng định đoạn nhắn nước, quan đủy chú cương, đứa đi tổng rằng,
đứa xử lãnh đạo, chỉ đạo thường xuyên, sự tiếp của bộ cố sòng,
tổng cộ khọc cần ký phật, sẽ ngài tăng phát triển, lớn mạnh,
kế thử và phát triển thống phải vang, nếu thao ít tâm đoạn kết,
chủ động sẵn tạo trong mọi người, công tác,
qua thành tăng lượng như bụ đứa rau,
mai mai xứng đạo với những video của đáng, nhắn nước và nhắn gần.